and tens of thousands of hungarians have
rallied in budapest to commemorate an
anti-communist uprising in 1956.
supporters also turned out to back
nationalist premier victor orban he's
facing a united front of opposition
parties in elections next year
the vote will be the biggest challenge
to urban's authority since he came to
power in 2010 and it is expected to be a
close contest
i'm now joined by stefan boss a
journalist in budapest stefan thank you
so much for joining us and we just heard
tens of thousands have attended this
pro-orban rally what does this tell us
about his popularity in hungary
well it tells us definitely that his
popularity is still strong and i think
it will be a very uphill battle for the
opposition during the elections which
are expected in april
of course there were tens of thousands
of people that is also the poor base i
would say of the prime minister victor
orban but at the same time there were
also thousands of people here behind me
uh just an hour ago
when actually the um
candidate for the opposition peter
marquis sakai was
talking here and actually
he was making clear that he wants to
fight for freedom he spoke with
the thousands of supporters here so they
were definitely here as well in hungary
today
and does the candidate for the
opposition
pose a serious challenge to urban's rule
well you know i think they feel that
they have definitely the possibility to
uh
show a clear challenge to the hungarian
prime minister viktor orban i also spoke
today uh with
the opposition candidate for prime
minister mr peter sarker
he basically told me that he when he is
prime minister he wants to fight for
freedom and also to make sure that
hungary becomes part of the european
prosecutor's office which is not the
case now
he feels that he has the momentum but i
also have to say it will be a very tough
battle because opinion polls also show
that the ruling fetus party is still
slightly ahead at this hour and at this
moment so we have to see whether this
this really made a difference
stefan just before we go briefly if you
could could you give us an idea of this
commemoration of the 1956 national
uprising i mean how significant is it
for today's hungary
it was a very significant day of course
to hold the israelis uh today is the
65th commemoration of the 1956
revolution against
communism and against the soviet
domination and of course
this was also a crucial moment for the
opposition to gather here and uh yeah
people still remember how 200 000
hungarians fled this nation thousands of
people died so it is definitely
something that remains in a way an open
wound uh for hungary uh but the
opposition hopes that if they come to
power that they will introduce the
freedom that they say the 1956 fighters
were fighting for
stefan bosino budapest thank you very
much for that update
you